[Music]
the micro environment has always
fascinated me i was not even in grad
school yet
and i heard mina basel give a talk where
she showed
a cell that she had taken from the
prostate and put in a mammary micro
environment
and that cell actually started producing
milk which i thought was the most
fascinating
experiment i'd ever seen
professor ashani ratna has been studying
the cellular micro environment in her
lab for the past
17 years cells don't live in isolation
the other cells molecules and blood
vessels in their surroundings can have a
powerful effect on their behavior
and this is especially important when it
comes to cancer
so the tumor micro environment is really
the neighborhood in which the cells
sit they sit in a network of
matrix and mesh and they
have other cells that are around them
and the impact and the crosstalk
of those cells with the tumor cells can
have a huge
impact on the behavior of the tumor
cells outside of genetics
my lab and others are looking at the
impact of aging
of normal cells in the tumor
microenvironment and how those
impact cancer development and
progression
it's such an obvious thing
that cancer and aging go hand in hand
and yet despite that
until we've really started digging
around i don't think even i realized how
important it would be to
understand what those changes are and
how we can target them
cancer is often defined as a disease of
aging and the vast majority of cases
occur
in people over the age of 50. as global
populations live
longer cancer is set to become a major
public health burden
so how does an aging micro environment
around a tumor
affect cancer progression what we're
finding is that the cells that are aging
normally as they're supposed to do
around the tumor cells are sending
signals to those tumor cells that make
them
more metastatic and more invasive and
more resistant to therapy
for example if you look at the skin we
see collagen
that is nice and firm and very dense and
younger skin
but that we lose that density and that
firmness
in aged skin and that provides ways for
tumor cells to move differentially
through that collagen also immune cells
the immune system changes dramatically
as we age
and what we're finding is that there are
changes that are both beneficial
as well as detrimental in the age tumor
microenvironment
so for example in melanoma patients are
often treated with therapies
that boost the immune system so
immunotherapies and
we find that older patients actually
respond much better
to immunotherapy such as anti-pd1 than
younger patients because they don't have
the same level of regulatory checkpoints
that
younger patients tend to have
so one of the things we've been most
excited about recently is the fact that
we have
found changes that occur in tumor cells
that we put into age microenvironments
rather than young microenvironments
and we can actually target those changes
we see those changes in patients and
when we target them in mice
we can overcome therapy resistance and
reduce metastasis
and so that is fascinating and we're
hoping to push that into clinical trials
over the next few years
so our research is currently paying
enough attention
to the effects of the aging tumor micro
environment
as a community we're not really taking
the aging micro environment into account
we are designing pre-clinical studies
that are all based in
six to eight week old mice we don't
really tailor our therapies from young
to
older patients our work has revealed
that older patients respond very
differently even to targeted therapy so
that has been a really fascinating
finding for us because one of the early
experiments that we did
was to take uh genetically identical
tumors that bore a mutation that we
could target
and yet when we put the same tumors in
either a young mouse or an age mouse
what we saw
was that the tumors in the age mice
despite the fact that you had one gene
and one
drug to target that gene behaved
completely differently
i think one of the most important
milestones we're gonna see over the next
five to ten years is the movement of
some of this work
into the clinic so for example the
target that i was speaking of
earlier is a target that we can make a
drug for
which we are doing and then get into
patients in a clinic
i also hope that people will start
thinking
about designing preclinical studies in
young and aged mice
we're beginning to show that there are
differences in older females and older
males
so i think that's going to be an area of
great importance
as well and finally
really what i'd like to see is the way
we treat patients
how important it is to treat them
according to their
[Music]
age
you